avocados are awesome I love avocados I
used to not like avocados you love
avocados avocados are good on something
what then it tastes like nothing I feel
like when you eat avocado it's normally
savory like it's certainly with some
kind of meal some kind of entree so it's
hard for me to think about drinking it
I don't know now that I see it I can't
have oh it looks like ice cream oh it
smells like just like avocado ha smells
like memories avocado Cheers
hmm I like it I can't tell if I like it
or not you do I mean I think I do yeah
when I think about it I can do this is
about a thousand beer
well it tastes like grass it's like the
texture of like yogurt it's like a
vanilla milkshake with a kiss of avocado
I don't even say like a like a fruity
milkshake really just my old one where
are you getting that from
I don't know I like it the more I drink
it it keeps getting better and better
but my brain is going crazy because it's
like wait the ice cream yeah thank you -
this into hollow hollow
instead of like ice cream on top and now
be pretty bomb is there Alvah kado ice
cream avocado ice cream
10 out of 10 would loop again yeah and
if I ever give birth to an offspring
probably gonna make them think this is
ice cream for about 12 years
just live yeah just be like this is a
sweet treat